[Music]
the c-class was launched back in 1993
the smallest rear-wheel drive Mercedes
and the car makers representative in the
compact executive range the new addition
is now the first in its class to boast
adjustable air suspension the c-class
has also been stripped of a good few
pounds to further improve its handling
with the hood trunk lid and roof now
made of aluminum
but intelligent lightweight engineering
led to a weight reduction of 100 kilos
explains Marcus kirbo Mercedes managed
that by using a lot of aluminum a door
made of aluminum weighs under 10 kilos
for example compared to the previous
model that's a weight saving of 30%
life-supporting oil as the sunny side
spa home from classic percent the
biggest benefit for owners from that
lightweight construction and lowest
aerodynamic rating in its class is fuel
economy we tested the c220 BlueTEC
diesel which consumes just 4 liters for
100 kilometers co2 emissions are low at
103 grams per kilometer while the top
speed is high at 234 km/h most of those
who've tested the new c-class are
impressed turtle is Michel Schmeichel
loves the road holding and grip it's
been built around the driver making you
and the car one with thoughts against
myths and there's plenty to savour
inside too with top class materials and
workmanship the new addition underlines
the models luxury sedan credentials
the control panel and the center console
enables you to alter the vehicle setup
all the most important information is
projected up onto the windscreen
[Music]
[Applause]
it's it's got nice dimensions you can
see everything thanks to this head-up
display at just the right height we take
it to the track to test the new safety
features first the braking assist the
radar sensors measure the distance to
vehicles in front if there's a risk of
collision you get a warning two and a
half seconds beforehand if the driver
brakes too softly the car will
automatically increase the braking
pressure for those 10% of cases in which
the driver reacts too late or not at all
we're going to demonstrate what happens
the sediments - sighs - ready and so -
nuts - I'm killing the father we're
doing 70 km/h approaching a slower
vehicle and I'm distracted by talking to
you I'm taking my feet away from all the
pedals to show how the car applies the
brakes itself the system works in three
phases
first came the alert then the car slowed
down with around 60% of the braking
power once a collision would otherwise
be unavoidable it slams on the brakes
the system also detects pedestrians
whether they're standing in the middle
of the road are suddenly emerging from
behind an obstacle there's also a
rear-view camera that can also trigger
the brakes if necessary and if an
obstacle previously hidden from view by
the vehicle in front suddenly appears
the safety system will engage
[Applause]
mushiya finds it fascinating it's ideal
for everyday situations where you might
be distracted that pedestrian appears
you're on the phone which you shouldn't
be it's a lifesaver
ideally every car should have this
[Music]
safe swift comfortable and economical
the new c-class has it all that said
it's up against some stiff competition
in its class from the BMW 3-series and
the Audi a4
live which ones on justice movement car
reviewer Hammond reckons this car sets a
benchmark its sporty-er than a BMW and
normally the 3-series would be setting
the standard in this class as far as
smooth handling is concerned it
certainly makes the Audi a4 look as old
as it in fact is Hammond says the
c-class is the car to beat in its class
the must rub those standards come at a
price of course the new edition will go
on sale in Germany for at least thirty
three and a half thousand euros our test
car with a smallest diesel engine costs
thirty eight thousand six hundred
seventy five euros
[Music]